on va faire le tour du château on
passera devant les communs mais on
n'entrera pas dedans par contre vous
vous pourrez après il rentre et on
passera également dans le jardin entre
autres le jardin des princes
c'est une balade d'une heure en plein
air le château de breteuil à choisel
propose une visite guidée tous les
samedi et dimanche à 14h30 et 15h30
une nouveauté pour le château qui doit
s'adapter avec la crise sanitaire les
visites intérieur n'étant pas possible
en attendant le 19 mai maintenant on est
content on a une date mais auparavant on
ne savait pas trop quand on allait
pouvoir ouvrir l'intérieur du château et
bien en attendant cette visite en
extérieur pouvait combler un manque de
culture de la part de nombreux de nos
visiteurs ce jour là il était de
visiteurs à découvrir l'évolution
architecturale du château de breteuil
mais aussi de ses jardins
vers 1900 il y avait des fleurs à couper
pour le château pour paris mais lisse
maintenant c'est plutôt des fleurs pour
les visiteurs pour qu'ils puissent les
voir de l'époque moyenâgeuse jusqu'à la
belle époque les visiteurs peuvent
apprendre durant cette visite les
différents styles
écoutez habitants du domaine qui se sont
succédé qu'est ce qu'on a appris balle
historique des propriétaires moi j'aime
bien savoir comme salles historiques
comment c'est arrivé comme ça comment le
bâtiment a évolué d'une ferme fortifiée
à ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
enfin ça m'a tout ce qui est historique
architectural j'aime bien autre
événement à venir au château de breteuil
une représentation de la pièce le
théâtre des contes par la troupe du
crâne dimanche 30 mai à 15h30 et 17h30